[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazine
donde les presentamos la actualidad del
continente africano en el marco de la 27
dedicamos esta edición al tema del medio
ambiente estos son los titulares
es el nombre de uno de los mayores
proyectos petroleros del mundo explota
un yacimiento ubicado entre uganda y
tanzania y levanta múltiples críticas
por las expropiaciones de tierras a los
residentes locales y por el impacto
negativo medioambiental la cop27 que se
Está celebrando en Egipto ha sido
descrita por muchos como una copa
africana pero veremos que los defensores
africanos del clima se declaran
decepcionados algunos de ellos
expresaron su malestar Tenemos reporte
de nuestras enviadas especiales a
Charles
Francia uganda y china colaboran en uno
de los proyectos petroleros más
desconocidos y más grandes del mundo
este plan llamado eaco ha sido objeto de
críticas y denuncias ante los tribunales
por parte de organizaciones ecologistas
el proyecto petrolero incluye una
leoducto de más de 1500 kilómetros que
atravesará toda uganda de oeste a este
llegará hasta la costa del océano indicó
en tanzania
Soraya Eibar periodista Eco editora del
sitio web de noticias áfricamundi estuvo
en uganda con dos colegas periodistas
para investigar este proyecto
Soraya Hola gracias por aceptar nuestra
invitación en primer lugar nos puede
explicar con más detalles de gigantesco
proyecto petrolero
bueno el proyecto
conocido popularmente como Jacob no
porque al final hace referencia a uno
leducto de petróleo crudo que se va a
construir en la zona de del este de
África en este caso en África Oriental y
en tanzania no este proyecto va a
transportar petróleo desde el distrito
de joyman uganda que está a orillas del
Lago Alberto para ubicarnos un poco
mejor
hasta una instalación de almacenamiento
que estará en la ciudad costera de tanga
en tanzania un recorrido de alrededor
casi de 1500 kilómetros
es el oleducto calentado más grande de
África y digo calentado porque
la temperatura del petróleo tiene que
estar a 50 grados o más para facilitar
el flujo estamos hablando de un oleducto
que va a transportar alrededor de
216.000 barriles de crudo al día a
máxima capacidad estará enterrado y ais
y nacen joyma la refinería de cabales
era como un punto de inflexión pero los
pozos de petróleo o el yacimiento
petrolífero sale de dos puntos no está
al sur es aquí en Fisher que eso está en
manos de empresa China y al norte está
el yacimiento petrolífero etilenga que
este es el que está que es propiedad de
Total energis que también es gran
propietario de Jacob y allí en el
yacimiento de tirenga se van a perforar
32 plataformas petrolíferas en la zona
de conservación de muchem Falls que es
uno de los grandes parques nacionales y
de los que bueno ricos en biodiversidad
evidentemente
la principal crítica es el abuso de los
Derechos Humanos especialmente en lo que
respecta a la expropiación de tierras de
las personas locales para construir el
proyecto Cuántas personas se vieron
afectadas por estas ventas forzadas hay
organizaciones externas que están
haciendo informes al respecto una de
ellas es inclusive development
International y en ellos calculan que
habrán alrededor de 120.000 personas
afectadas en cuanto a las conversaciones
sí que han habido sobre todo la zona de
la refinería de cabales han llegado
muchas muy tarde
también provocadas no por la pandemia la
covid porque un parón alrededor del
proyecto por por falta de financiamiento
y aún llegando tarde muchos muchos de
Los afectados denuncian no que han sido
injustas que esas compensaciones cuando
hablamos de compensación de tierras
monetarias se les compensa las tierras
por dinero ese dinero que se les que se
les atribuye nos ajusta una experiencia
actual de las tierras por lo tanto no
tienen la posibilidad de comprarse
tierras en la misma zona donde están
viviendo ahora mismo o donde vivían no
cuando esa conversación es de vivienda
por vivienda los reasentamientos tampoco
se ajustan a las necesidades de los
desplazados porque al final están muy
lejos duras escuelas muy lejos de los
centros sanitarios y nosotros vimos un
ejemplo en que caboga que es uno de las
zonas de resentamiento en la que los
residentes admiten no que la calidad de
las casas evidentemente tiene una mejora
significativa En comparación con donde
vivían previamente pero sí que alertan
de que su vida ha empeorado porque una
de las principales críticas es que están
en masa amontonados son la mayoría
agricultores por lo tanto no tienen
espacio para crecer a los animales para
para crecer las tierras para labrar las
tierras y sí que es cierto que es uno de
los grandes los grandes handicaps de
estos resentamientos que te cuento
y la segunda crítica se refiere al
impacto medioambiental de esta operación
que va a generar millones de toneladas
de dióxido de carbono entre otros daños
puede decirnos algo más sobre los daños
al medio ambiente
es un proyecto que inevitablemente va a
tener un impacto un impacto
medioambiental concretamente si hablamos
en la zona de joyman en uganda entre los
bosques de itoya y había que es por
donde va a pasar a cop su construcción
amenaza con cortar el corredor natural
de los chimpancés o sea un corredor que
utilizan los chimpancés las comunidades
de chimpancés para moverse un lugar a
otro y poder reproducirse evidentemente
si hablamos del Parque Nacional de
butinson Falls la construcción de las
carreteras en mitad del Parque Nacional
también están Están impidiendo el que se
muevan no los animales hablamos sobre
todo de jirafas de elefantes y estamos
también cortando esas esas relaciones de
reproducción que al final también
la parte del ciclo natural de tanto
dentro del parque muchinson Falls como
para el hábitat en general de estas de
estos centros forestales no
Soraya Gracias por estar con nosotros la
serie de reportajes sobre el leacop que
fue realizada en uganda y tanzania está
disponible en el sitio web african
report
vamos ahora
en Egipto donde se celebra la con 27 los
representantes del continente africano
que lograron hacer el viaje ya no creen
en las promesas de los líderes mundiales
Para aportar soluciones concretas al
problema del calentamiento global además
muchos consideran que el evento se ha
convertido en una especie de lavado de
imagen mientras que otros han denunciado
su exclusión del evento veamos
taxi machines acróstico continental
así levantaron la voz los activistas
africanos una de las pocas protestas en
la zona de negociaciones de la Cumbre
climática cop27 en la ciudad de
charmershake es que el gobierno egipcio
prohibió que las manifestaciones se
hicieran afuera del recinto y para
hacerlas dentro los activistas tienen
que tener la aprobación después de
llenar un formulario por eso nimo basei
sostiene que la Cumbre no es una
negociación africana a pesar de ser en
Egipto
Esta no es una copa africana si lo fuera
los africanos estarían acá pero para
esta Cup la gente africana no tiene
acceso no tienen credenciales no pueden
pagar por los vuelos para venir acá Este
lugar es tan remoto de cualquier parte
las personas no pueden pagar el
hospedaje y algunos ni siquiera saben se
discute aquí por 27 veces la Cup se ha
reunido y cada vez las cosas van peor es
la quinta vez que la Cup es en África
pero nunca ha sido para el continente no
es una copa africana
y la voz de los africanos debe
escucharse a pesar de que todo el
continente emite menos del 3% de los
gases de efecto invernadero aquí las
consecuencias de la crisis climática se
sienten con fuerza 9 de los 10 países
más vulnerables a la crisis están en el
África subsahariana como lo evidencian
las inundaciones de Nigeria uganda y
ghana y también la sequía que tiene en
hambruna al cuerno africano por eso los
las personas de este continente
Especialmente los jóvenes piden que los
países industrializados paguen las
pérdidas y los datos
por los próximos 20 o 30 años
enfrentaremos las consecuencias por eso
los jóvenes que son seleccionados de
cada país del sur global deben venir a
aprender más y regresar a educar a su
país el papel de la juventud es aprender
a impactar las vidas positivamente
creo que el norte global debe parar los
juegos y pagar por las pérdidas y los
daños
Este es el llamado que ha primado en la
cop 27 especialmente por parte de los
países africanos
cerramos Este programa dedicado al medio
ambiente con una perspectiva cultural el
festival de música
ha vuelto al Desierto de Marruecos tras
dos años ausente debido a la pandemia de
Kobe 19 esta edición pone en el centro
el legado y la sabiduría ancestral de
los nómadas transajarianos como medio
para afrontar la emergencia climática
veamos este reportaje de nuestra
corresponsal Sofía catalá
taragall el festival de los ritmos del
desierto ha vuelto a las dunas de
Marruecos tras dos años de ausencia por
la pandemia de Kobe 19
esta edición pone en el centro el legado
y la sabiduría ancestral de los nómadas
transagerianos para afrontar la
emergencia climática que afecta
especialmente a esta región
norteamericana
dentro del desierto hoy se considera
seminómada vive del turismo y cree que
el festival sirve para generar
conciencia sobre la sequía
aquí hay conferencias y formaciones para
concienciar a la gente para enseñar
sensibilizar sobre el peligro que viene
como consecuencia de la escasez de agua
somos las mayores víctimas y sin embargo
los menos contaminantes del mundo
tragal forma parte de la red de
festivales responsables con el medio
ambiente junto con otros certámenes del
Desierto de níger y Mali también es un
medio para promover el ecoturismo en de
Sakura que entra Es de rabat capital
administrativa de Marruecos participa
por primera vez en taragall le mueve el
interés por aprender de una cultura
distinta a la suya dentro del mismo país
Aquí aprendemos de otra cultura la
cultura de una región que no conocemos
en otras ciudades venimos aquí y estas
personas comparten sus enseñanzas Y su
tiempo con nosotros
y en el sentido de compartir la música
es el nexo universal
cae la noche en las dunas de Benjamín
del islam Y estos jóvenes inauguran los
conciertos se llaman generación
taragalls saltaron al escenario en la
primera edición del festival y una
década después siguen en el camino
a tocar por primera vez en 2008 nos
animaron en generación taragal hemos
hecho giras en Europa África y el magreb
[Música]
un camino el de la música que a pesar de
todas las fronteras mantiene vivo el
legado cultural compartido de los
pueblos nómadas saharianos Andalucía
estuarex amazix Y ante todo áfricanos
[Música]
así termina la edición de esta semana
gracias por su sintonía nos vemos la
próxima semana
[Música]